[Musique]
l'insectarium de montréal ouvrira à
nouveau ses portes cette semaine dans
son tout nouvel espace nous avons suivi
les équipes qui ont vu à la métamorphose
des lieux il ya la sélection des
insectes qui seront en vedette
[Musique]
l'endroit est calme et tropicales inondé
de lumière
mais bruyant d'insectes pour les
amateurs c'est la maison du bonheur
pour les autres il lui inspire un peu
terre
mais souvent on a peur de ce qu'on
connaît mal mais ce qui est très loin de
nous c'est que d'avoir l'opportunité
d'avoir un contact privilégié avec les
insectes comme ça on espère que ça
contribue à faire évoluer la mentalité
déjà
s'il défie du nouvel insectarium de
montréal émerveillé sans effrayer comme
70% de la collection à l'échangé il
fallait procéder à une sélection et on
n'a pas idée à quel point le choix de la
collection vivant d'insectes a été
déterminé par les appréhensions de ceux
qui viendront les visiter alors nos
critères principaux c'était que
l'insecte soit donc des urnes qu'ils
soient actifs mais qui se met pas à
voler partout on veut pas que le
visiteur rang dans la serre et que les
plein d'insectes qui volent dans tous
les sens les papillons bien sûr ont
préséance ils se relaieront maintenant
en tout temps de l'année
pour ce qui est des autres insectes on
les a voulus petits comme les fourmis
statique comme les insectes feuilles
ou encore sans capacité de vol
de coléoptères qui sont des ténébrions
ces décos d'attaquants la
caractéristique d'avoir les élites c'est
à dire les élevez vous soudée donc ils
volent pas ce que c'est très intéressant
pour nous de les utiliser dans un
contexte de semis contention les sont
incapables volée
c'est ce qu'on est capable de les
reproduire d'avoir un élevage constant
toute l'année sur la plupart des espèces
on va vraiment essayer de les élever ici
de les reproduire ici pour essayer
d'avoir en continu en fait des
populations pour être le plus possible
autonome
en parallèle à la construction du nouvel
insecte terium les entomologistes
sélectionne les nouveaux insectes qui
arrivent d'un peu partout dans le monde
étant d'en faire l'élevage
c'est la même forme instances et les
sillons sur l'abdomen mais la plupart du
temps on n'a aucune information même
dans son habitat naturel sur quoi elle
se nourrit c'est quoi son cycle commence
reproduit ou est ce qu'elle peut on a
vraiment aucune information donc on y va
à tâtons c'est les recherches on prend
beaucoup de données
il aura fallu beaucoup de patience
parfois des semaines parfois des mois
avant de voir les yeux et clan
il ya un apport au niveau des
connaissances qui vont servir par la
suite à documenter des nouveaux stades
certains insectes étaient peu connus
tous les protocoles d'élevage sauveront
ils vont être publiés vont être
documenté partager aussi donc de ce
point de vue là il ya un apport
important
pour les chrysomèles grenouille par
exemple les rares publications à son
sujet laissé entendre qu'elle pouvait
sauter
sont incapable de sauter on dirait que
la leur patte les handicaps vous même
pour marcher donc juste en les observant
dans nos laboratoires et puis on faisait
les expériences qu'on a on a démenti le
peu de littérature qui avaient été
écrites dessus
on un laboratoire vivant maintenant en
temps réel qu'on veut utiliser pour
faire des recherches parce qu'on a des
conditions stables ici on peut isoler
des paramètres d étudier le comportement
des insectes chose qu'on pouvait pas
faire par le passé
évidemment élevé des insectes et les
étudier c'est une chose le rebâtir un
habitant c'en est une autre
la ventilation ne doit pas perturber
leur vol
l'humidité doit être contrôlé
on vise à voir si cette variabilité d'un
à deux degrés maximum en température or
visant 60 % d'humidité
même si les conditions climatiques sont
bonnes encore faut-il que les insectes
s'y adapte et s'y sentent chez eux donc
on est dans les derniers préparatifs
les aménagements horticoles on va
bientôt apporter les insectes dans les
contentions on a un test environ un mois
pour assurer le bien-être des insectes
pour une des éléments majeurs auxquels
il faut penser ce sont des plantes elles
n'ont pas que rôle décoratif
en fait moi je produis les glandes pour
nourrir les insectes
alain farriol la production de kinect
alpes agnelli frères nourricier vassard
ici
mais encore faut-il voir comment les
insectes vont en tirer profit quel
ravageur pourrait s'inviter dans les
cultures
oui on va redonner se presser seul qu'on
va avoir des taux pourrait permettre aux
actionnaires avec la fan faire le point
aujourd'hui mario prépare le terrain
pour ses protégés des il est au dess
californie cas de la famille des
ténébrions des insectes qui ont tendance
à se cacher du soleil direct ans en
fruits sont dans le sol ou en se cachant
sous un morceau de bois donc j'essaie de
placer
les agencements de morceaux de bois de
façon à ce qu'ils aient une cachette
mais qu'on puisse quand même les voir
c'est beaucoup plus facile à dire qu'à
faire
dans un espace vitré restreint comme le
vivarium on doit aussi limiter la
reproduction des insectes
sinon cela peut devenir catastrophique
donc je dirais qu'on a autant de
2,2 défi à pouvoir reproduire une espèce
et à ne pas la reproduire trop pour pas
avoir de surplus
comment limiter la multiplication des
insectes chez les faces mais les feelies
par exemple on va relâcher uniquement
les subadulte des insectes pas encore
adulte parce que dès qu'ils sont adultes
en fait il ya certains ans et qui n'ont
pas besoin de mal pour se reproduire
donc ils se reproduisent par clonage par
parthénogenèse alors il suffit juste
d'une femelle pour avoir des centaines
de bébés en quelques temps une raison
pour laquelle dans certains cas on ne
relâche que des insectes mam
dans une zone plus sombre de
l'insectarium on prépare les tête à tête
c'est une vitrine miniature vers
laquelle on plonge pour se coller aux
insectes les plus remarquables
les chrysomèles greno et c'est vraiment
un bijou ça va être une petite merveille
ou les bijoux on en a aussi réuni dans
le dos rond
des insectes sur 360° assemblée par
thème ou par couleur comme des tableaux
mais c'est l'effet d'un temple qui va
montrer toute la biodiversité du monde
des insectes les colorations les
structures
[Musique]
besoin jaloux a même été porté à la
dissimulation des épingles qui
soutiennent les insectes c'est comme ces
spécimens l'oeuf le tew
c'est comme s'ils étaient suspendues un
peu de danse
dans ses vitrines d'exposition
un monde de biodiversité qui est
aujourd'hui menacé on parle maintenant
deux décennies pour une perte de
biodiversité allant jusqu'à 40% des
insectes à travers le monde alors que
par le passé c'était des centaines
d'années dont on veut vraiment avec ce
changement de perspective lent et
s'élèvera à les valoriser à voir les
protégés par la suite les protéger et
permettra six mille pattes géants comme
aux autres insectes de simplement
poursuivre leur aventure terrestre
[Musique]